- All right.
You know, I love to serve up.
I can't get past my band's chest hair.
No, it's awesome. I'm sorry.
But you do know also that I love to serve
up the latest and
greatest on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
Just a gift that keeps on giving.
You might have caught this
viral video a couple weeks back.
When a mom surprised her son with tickets
to see his idol, Diana Ross.
It was on April Fool's Day.
So at first he couldn't believe it.
- You wanna go to Diana
Ross concert today?
- You're kidding. It's April Fools.
- I texted you.
- Where is this?
- Texas.
- Are you kidding me?
Nah-uh.
- Come get a drink, you're shaking.
- I'm just gonna say, like 14 years old.
That's pretty great taste.
If your idol is Diana
Ross, I'm just saying.
And 14-year Louie was very overwhelmed.
And at that moment he
could have no idea just how
huge his Diana Ross
experience would become.
We have Louie and his mama, Kayla,
on the line right now
who watch on NBC 10 WJAR.
(audience claps)
What's up, y'all?
- Hi, Kelly,
- How are you?
I mean, Louie, I just have to say,
first of all, amazing taste in music.
I'm gonna lead with that.
(audience claps)
So Kayla, it was the sweetest thing ever.
And those tickets were for that
next night in a different state, right?
- Yeah. So Louie's been a big fan
of Diana Ross ever since he
learned about Motown music
through the show, Motown Magic on Netflix.
My youngest son watches that show,
and he really fell in love
with Diana Ross and her music.
So he showed me the tickets and he's like,
mom, Diana Ross will be in Austin.
I'm like, Louie, buddy, no,
we live in Rhode Island.
That's Austin, Texas,
cross the country. No way.
So later that I bought the tickets,
obviously didn't tell him until April 1st,
April Fool's day, as you just saw.
And 10 minutes after that video
we were driving to the airport.
I had our bags packed, ready to go,
checked into our flight.
On the way to the airport,
I whipped up a TikTok
and while we were on the
flight, it went viral.
And we got off and realized it went viral.
Saw the comments, somebody in the comments
mentioned that it was a benefit concert.
And we decided to link that
donation page to my TikTok.
And here we are.
- Yeah.
- That's crazy!
So, Louie, it turns out
that your mom's idea to
link the nonprofit made a huge difference.
So explain what happened.
- Yeah. So donations kept
coming in like crazy.
And we didn't even know
that until the ACGC
contacted us to join
them in their VIP dinner.
And after the VIP dinner they
called us both up on stage.
We were like, what?
And that's when they gave
us the front row tickets.
And Diamond Room gave
us our Diamond gifts.
And the concert, as you see, she came out
and I almost passed out.
It was over. It was insane.
It was the greatest day of my life.
- I just love that this started
from you just watching
something on Netflix
you just loved, telling your
mom, you're mom is so rad,
and actually went and got the
tickets and took you there.
That's amazing. You
have an incredible mom.
Kayla is amazing putting
all of us moms to shame.
Flying across the country. That's amazing.
Thank you guys so much, Louie, Kayla,
this is such a great post.
I'm liking it right now. Right?
All right.
And that's not all our
season long partner,
Pilot Pin Makers of G2, the go-to pin
of the Kelly Clarkson show.
They want to honor ultimate overachievers
and that's like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1000.
How about that?
- Thank you.
_ Thank you.
- Oh God.
Thank you guys so much.
I'm so glad you got to
see her in concert, Louie.